when I'm lugging all my makeup across
country or I'm having to spend an extra
30 minutes to get ready for something
and my friend Andrews just sitting on
the couch just whittling his thumbs
while I'm like having to put on eyeliner
in my waterline which means you're
poking in your eye and yeah I don't have
to do it but it makes my eye look that
much better yeah it's exhausting
Gabby there my girlfriend doesn't do it
your girlfriend doesn't do no makeup
nothing well she's also gay yes well so
am I
[Music]
Gaby Dunn is our guest right now Gaby
Dunn is a author comedian do you sell
just stand up no I mean I did
storytelling on our book tour okay so
yeah yeah just but just a funny cool
chick
Gaby done her book bad with money the
imperfect art of getting your financial
together is available online now
you have a book you wrote a book this is
like a nonfiction that is based on the
podcast bad with money that is like
about I don't know there John refine an
shal memoir is a thing now uh-huh but
it's like a financial memoir but also
like a help helpful book okay what you
have a you have a podcast called bad
with money yes in which you talk to
comedians and people funny cool people
about being bad with money tell me about
the podcasts for season one so I didn't
know anything about money I would cry
about it all the time so I'm avoiding
the issue I don't talk to you about
money that's why you're here to talk how
much people don't want to talk about
money yes I think I've had some people
be like I love you so much I can't
listen because it gives me anxiety yeah
so I get it yes but I I started not
knowing anything and I would cry that
was like my big thing and I would cry
about and I just was always in the hole
somehow and like always had dead and
never talked to anyone about it
and and never like it was like my secret
shame and then I had the opportunity to
do a podcast and they were like well do
you want to do something about LGBTQ
issues do you want to do something about
like sex positivity and I was like
actually the thing that I cry about
every day is money maybe we should just
expose that so this is working towards
it I know
so the first season which is super
healthy so so per season thing you're
most scared to talk about why don't I
start a show about it yeah that's nuts
well good for you okay so the first
season was me mostly talking to
comedians and other artists and just
sort of being like how do you make money
like how do you do this like what's
going on yeah what what's your situation
and I I you know moving to LA from New
York
I didn't realize like oh everyone some
people have their parents money or some
people have side jobs that I don't know
about or whatever so I would compare
myself
so much to other people without knowing
that they their situations were so
different from mine
yep so I would like uh you know we would
have the same income but I you know I
take care of some family members and I
had student loans and whatever and then
I would compare myself to people who
would who didn't have any student loans
or were getting money from their parents
yes and I was like but we have the same
income so how how am i struggling and
then I was like oh other people have
totally different situations and was
that the first step in kind of is that
the first step transparency is just
that's so hard cuz no one talks about
money I know up in a house where it was
like you you Nicky you don't tell your
friends how much your dad makes you're
not even a I wasn't allowed to know how
much money my dad made it wasn't like a
ton of money or it wasn't even or when
it wasn't a ton of money I wasn't
allowed to know either way why but in
the book I talk about I got such
whiplash because my parents would go
through phases where they would have
some money and then they would have
nothing he to and so there would be days
where they'd be like oh yeah you could
definitely like go with your friends to
this like you know whatever you could
you could go to the dance with your
friends and get a new dress and then
like two days later they'd be like no
you can't I learned the word destitute
really early on my generally say we're
destitute and I was like I don't know
what that and I had to like look it up
and I'm like oh no we're poor like I
felt the same back and forth of like do
we have all the money or none of the
money and then I would get stressed out
like which is parental izing where I
would be like you know twelve and my
parents would spend money and I'd go
should we be doing this yes oh my god I
remember the day I I mean I remember the
day I really were driving we were moving
from Cincinnati to st. Louis I was six
and I remember being in the car and
seeing the st. Louis Arch and just
having a realization I don't know what
conversation was happening between my
parents but I remember being like were
poor yak were poor and I am the only one
that's gonna make it so that my sister
doesn't spend my parents money yes
because they're not gonna tell her so I
started like yes being like Lauren you
can't come I would like take her side at
7-eleven and be like you might go look
at one candy Lauren I was hanging her
from my parents having to tell her
and just protecting my parents from not
being broke and fighting about it and
being scared like almost exactly the
same I have a little sister too yes and
she I interview her in the book and
she's like I had no concept I thought we
were fine I had no I I would if I she
was like if I asked mom and dad for
something and they said yes I would go
great we have the money so I started
being like telling her same I started
telling her you can't ask you have to
stop yes and then she got a lot of stuff
that I didn't get because I was like
well if she's in my mind because my
older brother also was like having
trouble finding a job at the time so
like they were helping him and so I
became like okay I should be successful
on my own because they're already
helping two of their kids so I need to
be the one that they don't help yes
which is so stressful to put on a
teenager yep I thought I would always be
the one to take cuts and listen to
because I wanted I didn't want them to
know that I knew either yeah I was
trying to protect them and I don't need
it exactly I know and that but I really
wanted it and I want I wanted all the
things that my friends were getting that
and I and you're right the transfers I
didn't understand like how does my
friend afford Abercrombie and Fitch and
when her dad has a similar job to mine
like I just didn't understand it and I
see I still the transparency thing is so
huge in comedy because I think that
especially for women we get paid less
than men a lot of times and as comedians
were also private about what we're
making and I'm like no it shouldn't be
private we should all talk about it
because we should all be getting paid
the same and more and and I think that
when you do find out what someone makes
you realize oh I need to be asking for
more I deserve more I had an interesting
experience where I was me and this girl
were both speaking at a conference and I
she deemed me to be like hey what are
they paying you and I was like oh that's
a great question so I told her and she
was like okay wow they're paying me half
of that so I said oh go to them right
now drop my name say Gabby told me she's
getting this and I want this yeah and
then they did they upped her feels great
and I was like absolutely for sure like
everyone should be doing that but people
get so uncomfortable when you know when
they're asked about how much money they
make both when they're not making enough
and when they're making too much Wendy
you're making a lot of money I want to
know every cent that's why I always
loved being friends with Amy Schumer
because I realized because she was
transparent about it she wasn't bragging
she was just like can you believe the
amount of money I'm about to get for
this thing and she would tell me and so
now I know I have these like I know what
I should be making at different levels
because I saw her rise right where I
kind of am and so I know what to expect
and I was appreciative of her telling me
that I never took it as a brag even
though some people could have but I felt
like it was it it let you know yourself
worth like it let you know what you
should ask for yes it really did and but
I still struggle even you know I'm at a
point now where I feel rich I feel like
I don't want for anything and I'm great
but there are days when I like if I
haven't I stress about money I'll still
find ways to stress about money I think
it's something I go to much like my
weight or my hair or my skin where
you're just stressing about something
else and you need to find a place to put
it there's a there's a huge difference
between broke and poor and I think I'm
still pretty broke like I think I have
like problems with like overspending or
like you know I immediately like my
sister had a thing where she was like I
went to the dentist and my tooth might
her tooth fell out and she's unemployed
and so it was gonna cost her like $1,000
to get a new tooth and I was like what
you can't be walking around without a
tooth so I was like oh she was upset and
I was like I'll cover it yeah like just
stuff like that where I I still do it
and I have a friend who's an actress who
was like so you gotta stop that right
now cuz now people now she knows that
she can just ask you for money but I'm
not gonna let her walk around without a
tooth like I feel the same way I only
want to make more money because I want
to pay for people to get teeth you can't
afford to eat I mean I really do I hate
the idea of these expenses that come up
in people's lives like I've lent Oh last
year I got like my money guy called me
and every year I'd read the call of like
how what my spending was the yes I don't
look at my budgeting I don't look
what and I kind of just know that he
sees it and it's gonna judge me and he's
like you're not the biggest things you
spend money on are lending people giving
away money yep and I'm glad di was glad
to hear that cuz I've never let money
and regret I haven't let money yet and
regretted it I've chosen good people to
do it for but it does feel like it I get
I get something more out of it sometimes
well what sucks too is that there's so
many medical GoFundMe 's and you just
get them all the time yeah another thing
and then means I throw so much money at
though I do too and then they're not
they're considered personal gifts
they're not considered donations so you
can't write them off on your glass and
really yes it's horrible
that's ridiculous yes so you can't write
them off in your there was an article I
just read that was like this girl got
some money for her cancer treatments and
then her taxes ended up being like
$19,000 on it right right so she needs a
GoFundMe for her taxes I mean it's not
set up our country is not set up well I
don't know if anyone knows that but
really
[Music]